Nicholas is with us in Grand Rapids
Michigan
I Nicholas how are you are you I'm good
how are you Dave
better than I deserve what's up I'm so
clearly I'm in school and I mean we've
been able to cash flow some part of
school but like I'm a sophomore and so
this is the second year and gotta take
out student loans I want to pause school
and work and save money to pay for
school but like that's not really fun
with my parents my dad just has to do
with better me my mom's afraid I won't
return to school so like I want I have
ten thousand dollars in student loans
and I want to like stop school return
later but say work and save up that
money to pay for it so basically cash
flow yeah what do you put emotional
school cost the school is about twelve
twelve thousand a year and we're able to
put about six thousand with eight
included so we have to take out a five
thousand dollar loan each year you know
well I think you need to make more money
well I am I'm working too well doing
studies currently working ATT part-time
and I mean when I go out in dollars you
know like I was losing them and I put
that towards that you yeah you're not
making I wouldn't put any money towards
dead I'd put money towards school that
night like a yeah and not taking any
debt it's only twelve thousand dollars a
year you're not my guys it's not much
you're not making enough so I but it's
like my schedules full of freakin crisis
in the work that I'm working yeah so you
didn't need a different thing to do that
makes more money well how much are you
making about a thousand two hundred a
month and how many hours about thirteen
twenty five to thirty a month yeah well
you work twenty thirteen work twenty to
thirty a week and go to school full-time
it's well it's with eighteen credit
that's kind of difficult
I did it I'm alive I work 50 to 60 hours
a week I was selling real estate
full-time I work two full-time jobs and
carried a full load and graduated with a
two nine seven and I'm not a genius so
hey it involves turn off the television
and probably not having much of a life
and maybe a different job that makes you
more money per hour but that's your
problem now you'll need to pause you
need to put the foot on the pedal and go
down even harder and raise your number
of hours you're working kick kick but
man that's the deal
that's what you got to do I don't know
if you're walking dogs cutting grass or
blowing snow but something needs to
happen man
somebody needs your help and you need to
find out who that is and they give you
money when you give them help
certificates of appreciation with green
presidents faces on them that's what
happens when you work people appreciate
it and I want you to do more of that
thirty hours a month no thirty hours a
week and that's what I'm running on will
be work all you know me at work I like
you're working way through college man
that's how life is most of us did that
by the way and so no I wouldn't stop
school and try to do no you don't need
because your school's not that expensive
you can do this both of you pick up
extra jobs sell so much stuff you can't
but the kids think they're next a dog is
hiding and the cats are hiding from
Craigslist on you know let's get with it
you can do this man open phones this
hours we talk about your life and your
money you know one of the things I ask
myself in situations like that with with
that guy if I'm that guy and I have been
that guy a time or two is what can I do
that is radical in order to get a
radical result because you're going to
reap what you sow if you if you put in
medium-level efforts you're going to get
a medium level result but what can I do
this radical it's over the top it's a
little crazy yeah and people are looking
at you like you've lost your mind
because most people are mediocre and
when they see somebody that's busting if
they don't get it their brains don't
screw in that way and so if you're not
making mediocre people nervous you you
haven't got a plan man you got to do
something that's different moves the
needle and here's the other thing hard
work it won't kill you right before you
die you'll pass out you're not going to
die from hard work you can put in a
bazillion hours for a short period of
time now am I asking you to
like that your whole life and give your
whole life to the work no that's not
what I'm saying
but for a short period of time I can do
almost anything I mean for a short
period of time you can go bananas and
that's what you got to do man and you
get results that way there's a critical
mass that's created when you put that
much force multiplier into your life
it's a critical mass and it causes
explosions everywhere all around you and
they're good ones this is the Dave
Ramsey chef hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh